this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
we got a very special guest on firing
kit today it is Trump's favorite fighter
Jorge Mosby doll kind of everybody's
favorite fighter let's be honest yeah
but it's special when it's Trump's
favorite fighter you and uh you and
probably Colby right yeah but he's been
the two of my fights in the Kobe show
it's a fair point dude I feel like he
sides with you a little bit you know
what I'm saying you know what I'm saying
and then he you'll never hear him
mention Kobe did anything for him in the
election numerous times interview after
interview he's mentioned how I which I
don't think I helped him but I he always
gives me a lot of credit for Florida for
the Latin community in Florida Miami you
know so uh obviously I mean it's on both
sides now you know in the personal
there's a mutual respect yeah when
you're fighting when you're out there
though and you have people like Trump
and you have these movie stars and stuff
does that ever do you ever think about
that when you're about to fight does
that ever get in your head when it when
it seriously could have got to my head
was uh when I fought Nate Diaz so The
Rock was given the Bell my favorite
fighter of all time the only guy that
that uh the one I've seen I was like
[__] I didn't even want to look him
in the eye I can't believe his [__]
throw it dude runs just walking out with
me and then and then Trump was saying K
side so before the fight I just didn't
care I like
completely 100 just zeroed out and I was
like I'll I'll have fun with all that at
the end of it whatever the results are
for right now I'm here for a fist fight
I don't give a [__] who came who didn't
come if my mom came I don't give a [__]
I'm just here to fight and you beat that
I gotta hate yourself yeah you got to be
selfish yeah I tried to kill his eyes
yeah I would give some of those rounds
ten eight easy man but when you said
that your your the fighter you couldn't
look in the eye what's up you know I I I
could look him in the air but initially
it was like man who's the fighter John
oh Roberto Duran oh yeah
I was like hey bro we're a little too
loose on the term fighter
I enjoy the guy myself
you beat the [__] up you know yeah yeah
I'm talking about man the greatest
lightweight of all time that that that's
when I first met him right there and at
first I was like holy I'm meeting this
dude makes total sense that that would
be your favorite fighter man it was just
like Legends I couldn't believe I was
there meaning and then I got to hang out
with him the night before
um my fight he went with us to have
dinner and we're talking and he's like
saying stores and be like I don't say
joking like punch me in the leg you know
and the first time I was a holy smokes
like you know it's a cool little Stinger
he did like three four more times I had
to tell him you're gonna [__] wreck
my leg down I'm not even joking I got a
fight tomorrow bro yeah it was just one
after another [__] just a dense dude
and that was in Miami right no that was
in New York was it in New York yeah oh
that's right that's right you think
about Duran who fought Iran Barkley at I
think 67. yeah 67 he was 38 years old it
was crazy man just would fight anybody
but you're kind of the same way yeah if
there was an incarnation of Roberto
Duran he but he did it all the weights
too you know he started I think at like
130 went all the way to 168 yeah that
was unbelievable yeah you you seem like
you're in I guess we I can't we could
say you retired from UFC but you're not
really retired you're I mean you're busy
as hell no retired from life never no
just retire when I when I got into mmh
because I wanted to fight the best in
the world always you know I I knew that
I maybe wasn't the best in the world at
my early stages but I knew my goal was
I'm going to make as much money as
possible and fight the best guys in the
world because that's what I want to do I
want to push myself to that limit so
once my reflex is mainly that started
slowing down I was like if I can't
compete with the best guys in the world
I I don't want to do this anymore it
doesn't it you got me like I don't wanna
I'm with you 100 but a lot of guys like
you look at like you know Tony Ferguson
yeah like BJ Penn they don't I don't
know if you're team Dean and the rest of
the boys I don't know if they're the
ones who are like hey man you like you
can still compete at a high level I
don't know if you can be world champion
like clearly Tony Ferguson or BJ Penn
doesn't have those guys but I also think
for you one of the reasons they might
they might have those guys but you know
yeah there's a reason why they're great
Fighters would you also hold up there's
also you also have a lot going on
outside of the Octagon like you you know
you have the game Brad fight promotion
you got your tequila like you're doing
all this other stuff so I think when
guys have other things to do it makes
that easier those guys don't have a lot
of the other stuff going on so I think
that's one of the benefits that I can
focus on this stew definitely you know
um and it sucks to hear it if a guy is
like still fighting because it's
monetary you know like I got like Tony
Ferguson I I would you know at the very
least and worst case I would hope that
he's set for life right like he should
never have to work again because of all
the money that he's brought in for the
company all the entertainment that he's
given us
um all the pay-per-views we purchased
with Tony headlining or co-headline you
know I would think he's good for life so
I hope it's not for the money but some
Fighters though even if they have the
money like BJ Penn's case they don't
care they just want to fight that's what
makes him great but it's also it's like
a curse too yeah when did you feel when
did you feel like you had lost a tiny
step
um all the way to like 34 35 it was like
if I was 19 years old with my reflexes
it wasn't really like maybe my hands
weren't as fast but reflex was I was
just as good and then power is something
that leaves you later in life as a man
it's the last thing to leave you so I I
felt that all the way up to that point I
was only kind of getting better my
reflexes were still pretty intact you
know
um around like 35 years when I felt the
drop off and I felt it in the gym first
35 36 getting caught on things yeah
getting paid how old are you now 38. but
but here's where his story is different
because obviously you're like you're
your big name in the sport but you
weren't getting your due you're always
like a hardcore favorite you know from
uh Strike Force and all that stuff in
the UFC everyone loved your fights but
then especially maybe to your I don't
think you slow down but you said you
slowed down at that age but that's right
when you started popping that's when the
big fight started to come and you
transcended into you know like the Nate
Diaz level and like people had so it's
like must-see TV so you might be a
little slower but it just happened so in
your career that's when you like caught
on yeah so you can't retire then because
that's what made yeah where you're at
now yeah so like 30 30 34 is when is
when it like blew up you know and um I
was still feeling good and it wasn't
until like 35 really that I'm like oh I
don't have the same like I'm getting hit
by guys that would never hit me before
and departments where I'm very good at
you know if I'm losing to a guy that's
really good in wrestling keeps taking me
down that's one thing but if I'm getting
like out struck by certain guys I could
tell like man something's like a tad bit
off you know so uh that that's when I
started noticing and I always told
myself when I can't compete with the
guys in the in the room and I have a
very good room to to judge my my skills
off some would say the bathroom uh
easily if you ask me obviously but I'm
biased I would say the best room in the
world um and and when I'm testing myself
against the best in the world
I'm starting the field now like it's
more even or I'm not getting the better
of guys how I used to well then maybe my
time has come I wasn't feeling like that
leading up to the Gilbert fight
I actually had a great training camp my
spine was great my my miles were in good
time like everything was good you know
but it's just five of the time when it
when it's actual game time and you're
going full blast I'm just like a
milliseconds Gilbert's a monster you
know as well so it's not he's a threat
on the feet he throws hard he mixes up
the grappling he has a bunch of
submissions you know he's a world
champion uh but I was telling you guys
you basically ended your career as well
as anybody could in this sport I mean
it's just a fact stayed colorful stayed
up fan favorite uh and because so many
of us have seen these great fighters who
just cannot let it go well everyone ends
up face down everybody if you stick
around long enough I don't care who you
are face down ass up like Jon Jones that
dude is like [__] been in it forever
too and like man insane what he's doing
yeah I think he retires and uh was it
the fight to November I think he retires
two years I think I think it makes sense
for him to retire there's not much for
him to do he's done everything the only
thing I think though is that going in
paper into the fight I think might be
his toughest matchup he's ever had
really just because of one thing that I
know for sure is going to come into play
is is going to be the wrestling right
like he I don't think he's gonna just
walk through the steepest wrestling I
think steep is a very underrated
defensive wrestler he's naturally bigger
than Jon Jones you can't ever bet
against Jon Jones I feel but this is
going to be I think his toughest fight
man I think it depends what version of a
week exactly two yeah yeah exactly
because it is
put on stupid is like 255 260 now that's
what he's been waiting to put on weight
see babe wrestled at Cleveland State
yeah like division one like stuff
wrestling yeah so he's going to be able
to wrestle back and and I've seen him
against everybody's fine nobody's ever
taken sebe down and written him out you
know I I just and that's a very grueling
tough fight if Jones has to do that with
a guy that could wrestle at heavyweight
it's a different pace you know so I'm
very excited to see uh how that fight
goes you know because Jones is just
Jones he just finds a way to win even if
his wrestling got shut down he's doing
something else but steep is also a hell
of a competitor so how did Bobby K side
for that one
how how did it feel to wrap that BMF
title around just engage these ways for
you um
but I never hated in the game because
I'm part of the game you know I've
knocked down numerous people in this
game and and so forth so
obviously I wanted to give it to Dustin
but the way Justin won is is how BMF is
supposed to win by stoppage by knockout
you know so um Bittersweet man um hats
off to him that he won he beat our team
but my heart's always with uh with just
an American top team yeah I love Dustin
but also with that fight like that could
have went either way like I thought
Dustin won the first round definitely
and got caught yeah like that that's the
bmfl title BMF title like just got
caught they fight again that probably
doesn't happen it could go either way
that's when you do it to him he was
screaming tell him you're screaming
I was screaming uh Dustin had landed in
the in the first run he had landed some
some body kicks that turned into head
kicks because Justin kept ducking in and
his arm was coming and he was getting
hit so I was yelling in the second round
Dustin head kick Dodson head and then it
happened I was like no not you not you
yeah and she was like Oh I thought
you're saying Justin
so they were like all clowning me and
[__] like damn I thought I thought that
was your boy you know
ah that sucked all right so I'm a coffee
fanatic
fanatical [__] dude
yellow now listen uh and that's uh this
is macadamia milk from House of
macadamia should I just put these nuts
in there no no no no no no no no they've
done it for you they've done it before
you watch this now what we do is this we
just take some of this Macadamia milk
and we're gonna put it in there we go
look at that that's pure Macadamia milk
right there all right I don't want Dairy
I I'm cutting down on my Dairy but this
is this is as good as good and healthy a
fat as you can get in your coffee so
simply add one uh packet of macadamia
milk to the base standard Shaker
now watch this I'm doing a bad job and I
just want to show you what I do here
this is 100 Macadamia shake it now
shake it now you shake it shake it shake
shake shake all right now that's milk
that's pure Macadamia milk look at that
right there now watch this from the yeah
from the nuts too watch this watch this
watch this there is my there is no I
like it I like it because it's good for
you so I don't have to worry about the
cream I'm not lactose intolerant now
watch this
taste that
oh that is nice see what I mean yeah
yeah and that's no sugar that's that's
100 Macadamia wait hold on so you're
telling me they can get the house of
Academia I'll give you 20 off wait use a
code use the code
t-f-a-k you 20% off and the macadamus
snack bars you got the variety pack
right here look at this dude get nutty
look at the snacks oh this follows me up
like one of them
[Music]
but now you got this whole fight league
and you got is it September 8th
September 8th dude
that's so scary to me these two giants
with basically no gloves that's that's
insanity and these guys are more hyped
than anybody in the world to do it and
it just becomes it comes from their from
their brazilianness from their
valetulaways like verdum is like the
more he wants to add Soccer Kicks to it
he told me at the press conference and
he pulled me inside he's like hey man
couldn't we just do like full value I'm
like no there's commissions involved
rules of regulations
there is a place in America that is
allowing Soccer Kicks where I am having
a show out in December
Denver and that's why one Championship
went there too because the one
Championship rules too never allow
sockets why would Denver have all places
I wouldn't think Denver I think it's
some reservation or something like that
yeah some reservation right some bingo
halls and uh have you seen Fabricio
lately that boy is bodied up oh man he's
Jack he is jacked Jack that's some good
creatine good luck I was gonna say it's
good creatine good yeah well that's the
acai in Brazil yeah acai in Brazil what
oh that's that's I got to get on some of
those supplements that's he looks
fantastic
that's nuts by the way
that's nuts are big what's interesting
about
um
about bare knuckle is it does seem like
if you if you just you can use your head
as a weapon to break somebody's hands
yeah you know I mean it's just all these
papers and that's why Mike Perry excels
in that because obviously like when he
fought Luke rockhold or or even uh
Michael Venom page those guys are
technically better Strikers but it's
just a difference
like Mike Perry just makes it ugly it
just beats these things and then that
little clinch holding release and then
he's adapted to the style yeah and the
distance completely different I'm
curious with JDS for Doom well I've been
in training room with verdum like he is
a he's a [__] like that dude
plays yeah he's a dog to your point he's
a dog and he's good in every area he's
good at wrestling good at striking good
at great at Jiu Jitsu if he's on top or
bottom
um damn JDS looking Jack too what is
going on with this acai in Brazil come
on and I've been I've had the pleasure
to obviously he's an American top team
have had the pleasure of watching him do
some some live sparring he's looking
good and I can say this is gonna be a
[__] phenomenal fight you know he's
been working with this guy a lot right
here who's that monster this guy's
killing people in the pfl they're trying
to line him up with uh uh
I don't think he's going to be up at the
final soon but yeah this guy's hurting
people and how hard was it to get those
two to agree do they come to you like
how's it work do you reach out to people
or do they come to you guys and jds's
situation and and I almost got to
apologize to him because I've been
hounding him for two years I see him in
the locker room when you go fight for me
man come on stop bullshitting he's like
man I spit all I'm with this company
right now
when I become a free agent next week I'm
like yo what's up bro look I got some
open space let's get you in there man I
got this I got that coming up blah blah
so it took like two years and he came up
to me the other day and he goes hey um
I'm free I could uh I'm a free agent let
me know if anything comes up and I was
like holy smokes so I called this dude
up and on the day that I'm telling him
I guess who's a free agent and is
interested in doing bare knuckle
and he's like is it a heavyweight and I
go yeah it's a heavyweight I mean Junior
dos Santos and he tells me goes guess
what I just got off the phone with their
manager and there's also a free agent
and isn't like ecstatic about doing bare
knuckle this is on the same day and I've
been trying to talk to JDS for like two
years but I hadn't really told him
because it wasn't concrete you know and
he tells me like right then and there
probably should be doing wants to fight
for us bear knuckle I was like the stars
on the shoreline
what a great friend you got to put
people on that card too right yeah his
brow in there no bro yeah we we had uh
some Visa issues we couldn't get around
in there but we wanted to get around in
there at 145 bare knuckle how hard is it
to get guys to commit to the bare
knuckle especially because you're
dealing with like free agents right it's
always a little dicey yeah it's a little
dicey that's a great word dicey and and
not every fighter in MMA is made or
meant to be in bare Knuckles it's just
different it's just different yeah
bullets are flying both ways you know
like you said you could easily hurt your
hand but you could also easily break
somebody's [__] iron we're fighting
with one eye the whole fight I know it's
a different bkfc but Luke rockhold broke
his [__] teeth off yeah yeah yeah
like that's why he stopped he's like
what the [__] am I doing I broke my
tooth yeah and then easily if they broke
your tooth you get a nerve slice in your
hand as well you know so it's it's just
a different sport also submissions go up
that's what a lot of Grapplers are
starting to be more and more into it
because you don't have these gloves now
so these hands sneak in there faster in
tighter places and you could pull off
submissions so submissions and the
finishes just go through the room hold
up your things you can strike and submit
it's MMA
hold on
he's a pretty uh criminal crop at one
point he was he would the only guy that
would fend off Kane in his prime that's
true
if her Doom gets to unrick and Paul's
guard and there's no gloves that's what
I'm saying why is that that's why
Grapplers he's so good at Jiu Jitsu
that's his that's his yes that's his
life why would it make a difference
without the gloves it just you don't
have the bulky gloves
yeah a lot of changes with with even
like your own grip strength you got the
tape the gauze the tape the gods to
protect your hands and the more the more
you have of that kind of constricts your
hand and then on top of you have the
glove now a lot of people usually train
like that so they get used to it but
still it's like it limits you in the
grappling and it limits I I one big one
is when you take somebody's back if they
have the glove I could like do this
correct
a little bit easier for the defensive
guy now if you don't have the gloves
these hands become a problem and they
get real sneaky and slippery in it right
here and once the hand is like back here
oh this dude this game over so so
Rogan's been talking about this forever
he's been saying I think we should have
no gloves because people will start to
learn how to punch differently it'll
take into other considerations I think
you're going to see a lot less I would
imagine punching that that's a big thing
every time you throw your hand in a
fight like that especially in the early
rounds that's a big gamble yeah you
might hit the top of somebody's head you
know it can be a pro elbows well it
depends on the guy it depends the same
time yeah at the same time some guys
just have mutated hands that nothing's
gonna happen to them and when they touch
your face they're gonna break your face
you know I see a lot of uh
like eyes getting shut you know because
it's just like it it's to me personally
it's worth the risk for shutting your
eyes your insurance can't be fun the
doctors oh yeah yeah we gotta yeah yeah
this past the commission yeah
um there's a lot of work it was a lot of
work one of the first ones was
Mississippi so shout out to them we had
about three shows there uh during then
we were we were applying in Florida and
trying to make it legalized in Florida
and then finally happen so when we threw
the first sanction bare knuckle show in
Florida and um from there we're just
gonna keep it moving Louisiana just got
legalized in Louisiana hopefully Arizona
soon as well Denver it's legal now so
we're going to Denver in December and um
when did you decide you wanted to be a
fight promoter like have a fight League
or three about maybe our first show was
about three years ago that we threw and
then it was more experimental phase you
know like I got ideas he already had a a
set motion and plan
um I had been to numerous of his shows
Island Fighting Championships and he had
maybe I don't know at that time 70 shows
you had already done by then so he had
like the infrastructure of it I had my
wing what I thought would do well for
promoting so we got together and we were
just throwing Concepts up doing the
stuff and um one thing led to another
the shows kept getting bigger our first
two shows actually for Bare knuckle
Mississippi completely sold out the
first venue was like 2 500 people the
next venue was like 3 800 people we sold
both of them out also it was right after
the corona pandemic so there's nothing
to do yeah so we went to Mississippi
where bare knuckle fights everybody's
like where do I get a ticket so we sold
that and that was like very confident
boosting for us you know we we barely
did any work for what we got in return
so we're like I like this you know I
think your benefit too is like all the
fighters like any UFC alumni every
Everybody [__] with you like you're a
good dude yeah get along with everybody
for the most part I mean maybe Ben
Astron Colby but outside that even
though yeah but those are just [__]
ain't nobody trying to be their friends
in real life those guys are just [__]
but you recently you talked about
fighting Ben Oscar
he's just a joke and a pun really but
did he he started right because he
showed a picture of him like in shape no
no no even even before that he he put a
con I had just seen the camera on my
actually my homie was there he is back
there look at this yes
you look like Tally from South Park
couldn't be higher
I'm so hard I've been looking at his
eyes and he's literally I've never seen
anybody hire that dude's scene I said
Jesus Christ that's that kind of pointy
[__] man yeah the weed out here in Cloud
Nine um
what were we saying uh about Ben oh yeah
I like Ben a lot because he he's I think
Ben is a lot sillier than people get
yeah yeah and smarter he's funny and
silly yeah he could be uh I don't know
irritating to me you know it's like a
lot of Fighters but I get where he is
you know he could definitely set a fight
um he put out something like I don't
need come out of retirement I told Dana
White for Jorge this loser and and I I
see that I go bro this guy is [__]
tweaking or something what's wrong with
you your reply was crazy dude you also
have the ultimate trump card like yeah
he just played a picture you know him
you know Ben like Flatline he's like
this full still talking you know he's
alive this Fool's alive and then out of
fun I was just thinking like if I walk
because I I don't want to do him as I
said or the only one fight the best in
the world you're not the best in the
world Ben sorry I could say that because
I've been in there with you you're
nowhere near the best in the world but
if you wanted to do boxing because
there's no needs allowed unboxing right
but I'd have to call Ben because I care
about Ben and I'd say Ben don't box
Jorge mosfidel I love it there's no
answer but think about it no I don't
want Ben boxing jorgeous very good if I
was even attempting it's illegal I'd get
disqualified so there at least he has
five seconds he doesn't have to worry
about the pain no let's just put all the
emphasis on it there's no knees no dude
no need I don't care dude nobody wants
your hands either that's a disaster
Ben's a great wrestler he doesn't want
your hands
I would do that I would challenge Ben
unboxing and then challenge Ben and
wrestling I got five minute rushing man
you think he'd be down for that I think
I think you'd be open to that wrestling
teams into it into it we'll hit up Ben
after this we'll hit a do a boxing match
get first you're gonna do the boxing
match get paid that makes sense Ben
don't say no Ben Ben's no here Ben's
doing frisbee golf and loving his life
and killing Ben called no I'm not the
one that called me out Ben wants to do
it he's broken he needs money okay step
in the boxing room do it but I think
we'll get on the co-main event of some
major boxes I will boost those paper if
you sell a bunch of [__]
pay-per-views I'll [__] I'll let you
live to like the second run so people
don't say oh you took them out too soon
and then the second one I execute you
via body shots boom I like it dude I
think and it works out for everybody I
can't help himself look at her hey now
I'm excited now you're getting me
excited and I love Ben but did you how
did you did you expect Ben to get
starched like you did no and that's no
disrespect Ben do you expect him to get
starched against Jake Paul I was calling
it I was calling before the thing the
only way I was saying he could win was
if he would have [__] wrestle [__]
him yeah and you can't wrestle [__]
rest in boxing yeah so you know but as
I'm sure you've seen and know been in
many interviews this is something that I
why I don't like him as a person as a
character has disrespected the support
of a man saying no I don't do pies I
don't do striking I don't do spot I just
wrestle yeah no I just wrestle and his
sparring is it and then wrestling and
then wrestling and wrestling so he
doesn't need any of these aspects right
well now you can continue to make money
off him because you never respected
these aspects and you need that in MMA
you need to be a boxer you need to be a
kickboxer I I wasn't looking forward to
crotch synth in anybody but I spent most
of my time training learning how to
defend that and how to stop that you get
Beau nickel bow nickel nickel go in
there and just rest the all [__] day
but he's knocking cats out you know you
got to respect the sport and he never
did that's why I would love to get him
in the boxing matches where did you get
your discipline man because when I
here's what I find fascinating about you
I've been watching you since you started
and you the one thing that guys like me
loved about you is that you were as
close to a human pit bull as a guy you
were game bread you loved fighting you'd
see a guy like you and you'd be like
that guy would fight you on the street
he'll fight you in a hair salon he'll
fight you right now you saw my backyard
with him to see it yeah where are you
and so
where you're like eight 17. 18. I'm
sorry he came out of the womb swinging
yeah but you see that spirit in someone
and a lot of times that's married with a
certain form of self-destructiveness or
a certain form of dysfunctionality and
so you end up loving them but they kind
of punch themselves into Oblivion
something happens it doesn't end well
typically but you have love in your
heart for them you're one of the few few
people
that I have that that what I find
fascinating is not only did you make it
the top of the game in MMA you also were
able to manage media in a certain way
you were also able to kind of like be a
personality and then you knew exactly
exactly when to retire and get into this
other thing so so there's this question
bro there's all this discipline and
there's well there's all this discipline
this mindset that's very rare I see in
Fighters because you go from fighter
pure fighter to businessman now to all
these other things so when uh do you
think that was something you were born
with or is that something you developed
because does it surprise you that you're
here doing this [__] combination
um definitely nature nurture and uh and
being born with with with certain things
and then through Society through my
upbringing sharpening those what was
that approved like who
um who taught you that [__] like I'm
very adaptable you know in that since
since a kid I moved around a lot I was
always for a long time I was like the
new kid in school New Kid in School
um in a different country since a young
age then I came back to America I lived
in Peru for like four years from four to
nine years old so then I came back to
America no English I don't pick in
English and I told you all I talking
like this every time and then maybe like
13 I started talking a little better so
imagine that was like more problems
fights in school things like that you
know and uh [__] I learned a lot like
during that time you know how to adapt
and right around then like I I fell in
love with the sport of boxing when I was
like seven years old that's the first
time I I discovered boxing then MMA
I discovered when I was like 11 12 years
old and I was like this is what I want
to do you know and I already knew um
because I had had enough fights moving
around growing up that I was gifted with
with like the hands just defending
myself you know I I knew that I was
pretty good at it you could see openings
yeah so I would go to the gym and uh I
could immediately like somebody been
training like two years if it was like
boxing for three years I I could like
hang with him I could do very well now I
didn't have the endurance because I was
so like new to the game and that I would
lose after like two rounds of sparring
in the beginning and and then I would
talk to the coaches like how do you not
get tired this is a crazy [__] and
that's where I learned discipline you
know it's like these guys run you just
started this thing but these guys are
like running in the morning hitting the
bags doing all these things you know and
then slowly but surely I started dialing
in on that and I realized like
discipline is almost everything because
as many gifts as I have if I get tired
if the Ferrari runs out of gas the Honda
Civics gonna get there first correct so
that that's probably what gave me any of
the discipline that I have in life comes
just from you know you know how it is
like if you go out Friday night Saturday
night Sunday night and Monday morning
comes no maybe you're the super athlete
that could get away with it in in UB
because that was me for a long time I I
was doing things wrong and I could beat
everybody in the room and that's amazing
you know but that wasn't the best
version of me it catches up with you
know and it catches up the guy with your
talent who doesn't who doesn't do that
you know
so I think the sport of combat is like
the greatest for instant gratification
and also like humbling you you know like
if you and just like three four weeks
you could change the course of your life
and like MMA really dial in getting
arrested so much when you were in the
game like when you started versus where
you ended the game evolved oh yeah yeah
yeah crazy right I had a crazy mutation
especially actual fast forward during
Corona like right before Corona during
and right after no it's like the sport
went 5x yeah why was that because
Russians were coming in people from all
over the world no they've been there I
think also shout out to Dana like he
kept the sport going on every other
major sport shut down doing we're not
doing that I'm gonna figure something
out so he went to the police he's in Abu
Dhabi still put on the fight so it's the
only big sport putting on so I think a
lot of new fans gravitated towards it
and they have stars like mods at all
they have Connor doing his thing so it's
just like this perfect storm of talent
entertainment and then they kept going
they just kept going the first event
back to full capacity was the UFC
Jacksonville when me and Usman fought
for the belt the second time that was
the first time in the in the States
since Corona you could have full
capacity and um that was thanks to Ron
the scientists you know and and Dana
White and they were able to pull that
off so that I think right there also
launched a sport to like another front
seat again you know because we were
constantly getting showed that the
fights remember were happening at the
Apex yeah they had all the guys with the
E.T suits shoving [__] bamboo sticks
up your nose and there's [__] bananas
I just think people respect and he got a
lot of new fans with that yep they keep
it going crazy
I don't know anybody watching UFC and
it's like ah not for me no like some soy
boys might be like that's too violent
okay but in general America loves it I
was thinking about you and uh Connor
what the hell what that would have been
like well it could still go down though
yeah man that dude it was really tired
him I'm retired but he'd come out of
retirement he fights as much as Conor
does because you could you know you're
right you know but the things that guy
that that guy's pissing hard clearly on
steroids cheating and then you're you're
calling out guys like Justin and Dustin
and this and that like man you can't
even respect the process you're so
[__] lost you're such a [__] idiot
the money and the cocaine has got into
that you can't you forgot the simple
rules that even made you like you have
to go and get on a [__] drug program
and not do steroids you [__] cheater
that's the curse of his success right
you couldn't even do that you didn't
want to [__] show up and piss on that
cup because you were gonna piss hot and
then you're calling out these Fighters
like bro it's so passy bro but I think
he's such a bum that I would sign a
waiver like you could fight me on
steroids yeah you could you could do
whatever you should yeah for him but I
feel like you could do it on even with
with your rules on game bread no no
because we're both signed to the UFC
still we're both athletes of the UFC
that you know how it is I'm just retired
not like
they freeze your contract so even like
when I retired I started I think of
maybe one fight left on my deal like
cool but if you ever decide to do
anything we own you still owe us one
more fight even though if you dip if
you're done damn how about you not like
you get a get out of free jail car like
oh new contract
you know damn enough yeah I know Dana
very well and uh and stuff but they
wouldn't let us fight on a different
League or nothing yeah it's Connor
you're gonna run some issues but I bet I
bet you could talk to him and maybe not
Congress somebody else you have on your
contract left I think um I'm gonna say
three some they got me that's forever
yeah
I have one and you know and they're dead
friends you get in there with me and a
couple other guys just real quick just
do a joke real quick and then just be
like I'm done now Conor would be the one
he's like nah man but but I I would be
willing to bet you're gonna get Connor
versus like a jake especially if Jake
wins on Saturday which I want your
thoughts on yeah if if Jake were to win
that fight and beat Nate I can see Conor
making that happen you know the boxing
match yeah yeah maybe they can make that
happen you you know and [__] as much as
I never would have thought this would
have happened Jake might beat America's
Corners like it's not crazy
Jake is out there training not doing
drugs not not being part of that [__]
vicious lifestyle this guy's like okay
in trouble you think Jake beats how do
you think Jake and Nate goes down on
Saturday I think it all depends on Nate
how how much of a how close is Nate to
his prime
obviously all day beats Jake you know
but
I don't know he's older he's coming into
a new sport Jake's been having the ball
roll you know and he he didn't look uh
phenomenal the Tyson fight but he did
prove on a technical point I I thought
that he got better as a fighter didn't
go his way and stuff in in a few on both
sides it could have been way Furious I
feel like both on both sides he could
have been way more aggressive it was too
much of a staring match but um when he
did decide to throw his technique has
got him better and and some of the
faints and stuff
um
I would I would say that
maybe Jake I'm leaning towards Jake I
want Nate to win because he's my MMA
brother you know correct UFC alumni I
usually stick yeah exactly my thing is
with that is how serious is Nate taking
it exactly Nate goes he's just a Disney
YouTuber he's gonna get [__] up Nate's
train like you did to get when he's
preparing for you Jake could be in a
little bit of trouble yeah but for Jake
it's all in those early rounds he's
younger he's faster more explosive but
if Nate it can eat the shots and apply
pressure and just volume he's gonna melt
it yeah well if it goes after four now
it starts I think
dramatically switched towards Nate's
realm and his type of real estate yeah
that's right I'm saying first three
first three if J10 success it could be a
good night in the office for Jake and
his fan base if he's not doing well in
those first early rounds he can't hit
him it's gonna be trouble Nate's gonna
[__] melt them
but also Nate gets hit a lot and Jake
can crack don't get twisted Jake and
crack I think it's a big accomplishment
on on for where he's at yeah for where
he's at in his level he can crack like
could he crack enough to get a prime
Nate out of there no but this name I
don't know maybe maybe now yeah you know
he's he doesn't I don't know he doesn't
see anything here's the question if Jake
loses where's he go I think like the big
names like the Conor fight's gone the
Nick Diaz fight's gone like him fighting
like legit MMA or boxing guys those days
are done I think he'll fight like a KSI
like he'll go the YouTube route because
I think Kim getting like legit Fighters
can be tough if he gets starts by Nate
guys
a guy that has such a fan but he's just
like Conor and stuff um I think they
could always just fight some taxi cab
drivers yeah they'll get a highlight out
of them and then eventually they'll get
to fight another
fighter or church UFC fighting you know
like a guy like Jake it just depends how
long he wants to be around even even him
losing this fight
I know what you're saying it would
definitely send him back but not nothing
that he couldn't fix in like 250 fights
yeah it's weird too because I don't know
if you saw like Nate and him were
sitting down with the Ariel Nate just
walks off yeah he's not promoting the
fight he's not he's just like and Jason
like being his promoter yeah
Nate's like buy it or don't I don't care
why he's just he doesn't it's very on
brand for Nate yeah like his his way of
promoting is not promoting right he's
too cool
Nate's still kind of like um is purest
like he doesn't like
he doesn't like that he's fighting
somebody who hasn't had as many fights
well then don't take the fight though
but if you're in a great thing some
fights like you gotta yeah they would do
that in in the UFC that's what I'm
saying
but not marketing yeah yeah it's very
strange it is it's it's it's Nate I'm
curious how it does pay-per-view was
um
what do you think
over a hundred thousand are on there
over a hundred thousand I bet they're in
the ballpark of 150 to 200. which is hot
I guess but mainly because I I just
don't hear about as much as I should be
I'm not hearing about this fight as much
it's just not with my face same number
so I would say uh lower than people
expect lower under a hundred thousand
buys that'd be a disaster yeah I don't
think no I think I think they've got
they've got pull no more than that so
I'm gonna watch it but I think I think
Jake's probably you'll be on stage but I
think Jake's prom is his young fan base
they just steal the stream you know I'm
saying like they're not buying the
streams is that what happened a ton of
it so if you add in a legal stream and
it's doing you know over a million but
they can't control like Dana can control
it's a business the fan base some of
it's younger but in general people know
that money might go to the fighters or
it's gonna help people out Jake's fan
bases y'all they're jacking it huh yeah
they're jacking it Russian hackers on
Playboy I'm gonna wipe you out
especially if you're on pay-per-view
um we've had a couple events with them
they're they're getting 45
right off rip really you made you saw
the million pay-per-views you're gonna
get 45 you get 55 now they have access
to like I forget like 88 million homes
something like that right that you can
advertise to you know how did the first
how did Jake's first couple fights do
you never really know but you know some
of the numbers came out for Wordly they
weren't they weren't crazy but like
Chael says this like even like we never
know like there's no committee that's
like yep that's real like when they tell
you Connor Floyd did whatever whatever
they said it was you know 1.5 or 2
million pay-per-views Trails like that's
not real
really like Manny Floyd like they're
saying biggest paper all the time Chase
like no that's not real like none of
those numbers are real why because
there's no committee okay saying you
know like you can see or you can't see
our audio numbers we can see YouTube
numbers if we're saying we got a 10
million you know downloads on uh YouTube
people didn't see it there's no
committee but somebody's making a lot of
money I mean the question the real
question is what kind of check are they
both seeing at the end of the day that
that would tell you a lot well people
are fighting Jake because they're
getting paid yeah I heard it wasn't uh
nowhere near that 500. yeah exactly and
then I see that it's crazy
then that's the first one too how how
are you feeling about like Leon Edwards
is having kind of resurgence like he's
like people are finally appreciating him
he's technically good man he's getting
more more uh aggressive which is I think
something the public probably didn't
really care for him you know yeah that
he that he would sit back too much and
not bring the action again as a fighter
you you're yes you're a martial artist
you're also an Entertainer correct I
mean you can't complain if people ain't
tuning in because you just which is not
Leon's case he's usually not well he
used to be a bit of a crotch Center he
went on that streak but if you're a
crotch snifferent [__] crossing
wrestler no not wrestler means you know
because there's a lot of I like watching
her beat fight person because if he
takes you down he's gonna [__] punch
your face in and I want to see that oh
he's going to try to submit you or if
he's on the feet he's throwing big bombs
to close the gap and then you know try
to finish if I when a guy's just get
into a lot of stop positions it's just
like wrestling and he's content to be in
the guard he's not doing any damage and
he's just like wrestling and wrestling
you know you're you're doing everything
possible in your power just to like not
fight and just you know playing it safe
playing it safe you know and uh it's not
really
it's not really like uh like a fight you
know I want to see a fight obviously
it's entertainment and it's also win you
got to be a martial artist he's getting
the flowers now I feel like a little bit
definitely that's his flowers down he
never got that two-piece on a soda
though
you know what I'm saying he got the
three pieces
and uh [__] if you want if you want to
like him doing his little interviews and
[__]
if he wants to spar for some money we
can like streaming somewhere I [__]
know what the [__] you want yeah and we
go hard for like getting around because
I'm a retired dad you know I'm not gonna
do five rounds but I'll do three rounds
with trash you're like she goes I'm a
retired Dad I'm a retire dad now I'll
break your face
I want a three rounds but five rounds
right now it's like oh that's actual
camera three rounds I always got what
are you wearing I know no [__] be
honest because you can't right now what
am I looking thick and I mean muscle
right now I mean fat you look you look
strong
right now I'm weighing about too sexy
I've had two dogs
155 it's so insane that you would get
that you know he'd get down to 74 it'd
be impossible yeah oh my God no no no 55
for you 55 was a nightmare just walking
juicy right now and it's pink at uh at
20 right around 24 25 my my body started
changing more started gaining more
weight so I went from like I used to
walk around 175 to like 184 and then I
ordered like 180 to 184 was my walk
around weight and then from there I'd
cut down to 72 and then pray to God and
and do the 18 19 pounds of water to get
to 55. right that's a lot of fun it was
a barrel on last when you're just
dehydrating yourself to that level it
sucked you know and then my last like
three fights I noticed like man I'm
[__] doing amazing in the gym but
when it comes to fight day like my fish
ain't flying the same like I'm just
straight I'm drained and then you saw
that happen to come in right at that
time and he took off IVs so I was like I
I can't I'll never make the weight now
I'm gone so I came up to 70. which was
like the best thing for me in my life
you know hell yeah maybe I should have
came in maybe like a year or two before
into 70 and just try to fill out you
know
um but [__] I always thought I was like
a little bit small for like a seven year
pound yeah at that time it worked out
for you though yeah my god did it work
out for you as far as we and I get
rolling pretty soon here as far as the
next BMF title which you're clearly
involved with now who who do you see it
going down with
um
I have no idea right I think they're
just like you look at them like yeah you
look at the lay of the land it's tough
yeah and there's a lot of interesting
matchups
I personally would like to see my boy
Dustin again [__]
fight for man there's so many badasses
I got hurt you know I know Jamal Hill
yeah who do you think solves that market
Chef uh wrestling the problem Islam huh
you know Gage is not a bad defensive
wrestler he's pretty [__] damn good
defensive wrestling All-American
All-American and he could wrestle it
could easily be gauging you know he's
got the power to do it I I could see
gaiji if he has a good night he could
definitely stop how does he stop that
that that's because you saw it and
definitely put him down on his back
pretty quickly yeah right so that's I
think Michael Chef would probably have
the same kind of they're a little
different though yeah
he doesn't have the the I don't think he
has the the power or quite the writing
ability of Habibi look at the
vulcanovsky fight a lot yeah no no
volcanowsky's I think a guy that could
definitely be Islam
and he took him down yeah I would bet
money on uh bulk I think bulk in for for
my money broke is number one right now
I get team beating all these guys dude
you know what the next BMF title should
be and I don't know how it works I don't
know if bulk versus well that would be
great but if you can jump around weight
classes Yuri versus Alex Pierre for BMF
it's fine hey bro
right there that should be it how is
Jerry is he back already yeah he's
training he's training and and then have
they given a date for winning they
haven't given a date but Mick uh man
you're stupid Yuri versus Alex Pierre
they they said is that's the fight for
the light heavyweight title let's
continue some more great matchmaking
that's what I'm saying bro I heard
you're making your debut on my promotion
you would hate that so much I can just
see you being like I gotta fight bro you
know what it is for me money it's money
yeah now I don't know you know what
listen to me this is a real thing
with the real thing
I'll be in your corner I'm there for you
that's good that's gonna help me wait
it'll help listen with my with my
[__] silver tongue in your ear and
you're like I can't do it I'm like you
got this bro you got this no you need to
distract my opponent the free agents I'm
sure as [__] if I ever Doomer JD
that's bro
[Applause]
and everything it's MMA come on bro I
wouldn't say no to Derrick Lewis if I
can grapple hey what the [__] Derek
Lewis debut in my promotion versus
Brandon come on man hey don't understand
that people's heads are just [__] are
you explode my head
look at my eyes there you go go get him
with your help I think look at the
intention Derek it's hard
like die for a double blast double hold
bars his hands just look like they're
already like mutated into something else
and I look like that'll hurt man we're
in the elevator with him before anybody
knew him we're I don't know if you
remember this he called me out after he
knocked somebody out I was like a Dave
and Buster's I'm watching the fight like
who do you want next I'd love to fight
Brendan Shaw I was like ah and I was you
know I gotta do I just beat Lavar
Johnson I was like ah [__] man it ruined
my night well we were in there I was
like eating chicken wings and like
we were in the elevator and he was I
looked at him and I started talking to
him I was like you're [__] Giant and
he goes he said yeah you'll hear about
me pretty soon we remember where he said
he said in the OC yeah I don't think
either one of us had ever seen him no I
didn't but uh but this is a this is a
I'm I'm actually like it and we don't
have to start with Derek Lewis first we
go he's the one who said it yeah he said
oh he did yeah somebody a little easier
well he was saying free agent so I said
yeah
we got we got another Community that's
it another comedian no no Louis CK
what's he going for boys nobody's going
to fight you in the comedy World
um I'd be the only one who would get in
there with you and and be a bad
situation for me
I got one friend comedian I'm gonna ask
Tim Dylan who
I don't wanna fight Tim what are you
gonna say Jerry Seinfeld
no no no I don't find Tyrone
Tyrone how dare you there's a good man
oh wait if there's grappling though if
yeah be it Timo yeah bro this is I'm
serious right now Jeremy Piven let's go
the sushi place right uh no it's that
Laugh Factory okay I think he has two
sets Jeremy I'm gonna tell him like Hey
Jorge's off versus
you got to contrary
to be a heavyweight it's got to be a
heavyweight and preferably somebody who
comes out of retirement as well
Tito Ortiz so we can make that happen
yeah
I'd fight Tito fight Tito
Ryan Page
Rampage isn't a bad idea it's my boy no
it's thinking no I'm nervous man hey I'm
nervous hey man
how old are you now I am 40 27 years old
yeah I'm 40 Doug you're 40. I'm 40. I'm
a dad dude
oh I saw a headlight you were saying
when you see your son hit mitts yeah you
want to cry yeah bro [__] how was he
eight years old and he can hit
um why I didn't I don't want him to be a
fighter right I just I don't I don't
remember that I already did it for him
exactly you know go go to school you
know let's learn about business go open
up businesses your dad's got your back
that's that's my plan right but for a
while now he's been asking to like train
in martial arts it's so much the the
last year and changes he's been nice
he's like I want to train with your
coach my my head striking coach Paulino
Hernandez he's been asking for some time
let me train with him let me train with
them so maybe I don't know I'm gonna say
about we started nine weeks ago
he started training with my coach we
started at three sessions a week now in
15 minutes now in 30 minutes
and the progression that he's had in
that time is [__] insane bro it's
like how cool you're born with it you're
just born with it
what the [__] and I you know I had left
for like uh three days four days to
promote I came back and he was doing
like weaving drills and dodging drills
and I was like holy [__] smokes bro this
is crazy it's nothing cooler it's the
best it's crazy man and it's just uh
what God gives you it's amazing how it
works if we could pass it give it on to
our Offspring it's nuts you know it's
nuts I also haven't been wrestling
because it's like uh he he's always
wanted to do the strike himself I'm
going to put him in the wrestling you
know so he doesn't want to like fight
too much of this and then he likes
arresting and he's all right because
he's very quick but where his gift slide
just like me isn't like [__]
strikings bro holy smokes nothing better
head kicks already throws one two's
fakes you know now every day now the new
thing is like I want to partner to try
the things with I want a partner so now
he wants to spar ready and I'm like
right yeah if I let them taste that no
this would be usually like a good age to
start letting them spot with a big
gloves gloves you know they'd just be
touching each other not hurting each
other but I'm afraid
that he's gonna bite and then when he
bites and he takes that blood that's it
you see a video in backyard brawling
like yeah yeah like they'll just [__]
dude though damn so yeah yeah it's
definitely in the blood it's crazy my my
daughter's uh very gifted in the
hospital but thank goodness she does not
care to fight thank God she doesn't want
to fight or nothing like that she's how
old 14 now but she got gifted with uh
with hand speed and stuff like above
average hand speed you know it's a good
chance of tools just yeah
and I had to train Jiu-Jitsu for about a
year and a half just so she could defend
herself yeah so every so often I take
her back so she just like it's like
riding a bike you know at least like
yeah
p's and q's that's uh that's my baby
girl right there yeah grow up dog my
little my little man and my daughter is
like my my family for sure everything
you know it's me my mom my dad my kids
and that's pretty much it yeah wow
nothing better brother well we're
looking forward to your fight we know
you got to get going you gotta start
training so I don't know oh my God could
you imagine this dude oh my God you
might have to start training well we've
been trying to first we got to get him
to at least commentator when we were
trying to get him a commentary one I'm
down for that
see the vibe and then when we have some
somebody wins here and then maybe he
gets excited and goes in the ring and
then we have the face off I'm getting
this here are you getting the other here
and then you know he's weak he'll he'll
end up going on okay so everybody
watching the show because everybody's
gonna start sending us the messages you
have to be a heavyweight you have to be
retired yep
don't get it twisted he's been coming
out of retirement he's still got dog in
him he does have dogs that dog never
leaves I'm telling dick jokes tonight I
know but you still got you're the kind
of guy though if you get in somebody
kind of insults you a little bit or
messes with you all right
he'll get he'll be like you know we're
playing volleyball in this rather famous
comedian female goes I thought you're a
pro athlete I thought you'd be a friend
he goes I I thought you'd be better I
spiked the bottle of it he he literally
just realized that I just saw him dead
seriously he looks and he looks at his
his trainer at the time and he goes we
have to win yeah she still spiked that
ball right and everybody get out spike
in her face so he'll he'll get it going
just we just got to get him going do you
you play football still ever you missed
I'll play cat because my son's in
football now he's he's really into
baseball whatever he's into that's what
I get yeah yeah that's how it goes dog
but you don't play like with your boys
ever like no like that no no no no how
about spawn you still mess around I'll
hit MIT still I'll hit mitts like
there's a like George Foreman's son owns
a gym literally across the street here
so I go there all the time right and
she's I just I like the gym Vibe like
the guys you know I can start sparring
let's find an opponent for Brian too
we'll do a tag team I'll do it I
wouldn't I would actually do it I need a
guy who's like you know in his 50s or
40s or 60s I'll fight I'll find pretty
much anybody unless as long as they're
not pro dude hear me out Biden
it'd be cool be cool okay bro all my
ideas here Biden gets on the mic and
mumbles I get nervous thinking about it
because I would take it really seriously
I think you in that guy in the debate
he'd catch a heart attack and just
[__] Crow
this is the greatest [__] I've ever
seen in the history don't get us started
brother we'll talk about
with you guys um
in in on air in many occasions my
parents escaped communism socialism so
since a kid this was just a Hot Topic
constantly hearing about it constantly
consequencing so my theories don't come
off like some YouTube video that I saw
like two weeks ago yeah it's just like
the life experience is exactly Venezuela
Cuba what's happening in Costa Rica is
trying to lean very hard that way
um I just feel like the Communist party
has infiltrated like the Democratic
party and
the idea of socialism the idea that you
can socially engineer equality with a
huge government bureaucracy it's just
power and it only power to them that's
right De Santos wins has a shot I mean
you can be sad if he leaves Florida and
that that is a thing that we I think all
of us Floridians are like we're losing
the greatest government in the history
of Governors but if it's to a greater
good to serve as a president you know
but also he's got a he's got the tallest
building he's got the tallest building
the boys
no but he should be EP
but I I don't think the sentence maybe
it's an ego thing he doesn't want to be
I wouldn't do be because you become
invisible and and anybody who gets close
to Trump tends to the things don't work
out a lot of times so I would say he
should stay governor of Florida if to
let Trump go through this thing he's got
Trump's got a lot of things to deal with
with these indictments but wait another
four years man
in Florida and then go crush it that's a
young man dude he's got time that's the
exact same plan that I would want so I
could keep him as my Governor again and
then let Trump because he's also older
what we don't want we don't no Trump's
77 you know let him let him let him go
now let him do his four years and then
let DeSantis come for eight years
straight and just and a lot of people in
Florida don't want the scientists to win
because they want him as the governor
you know we're taking to say it's right
now
I would suggest that desantis's team
knows exactly that so typically comes
you ever watch somebody becomes
president you you you you make a run it
takes a while knowing that you just get
yourself out there knowing you're not
going to make in the primaries but you
make a run you may get familiar with you
go back to being Governor now we're like
oh that guy that now people like us are
talking about him running the next time
the Santa's in the headliner yet he's
still a feature that's right still a
feature but here he's up against Trump I
mean if if just Trump wasn't there I
think he'd smash everything every
Republican he would smash him Trump is
just too entertaining and it's just like
not overnight it's a long lineage of of
freaking the Trump show you know do you
ever talk to Trump about like hey dude
you gotta you can't like Colby do you
have a car no I never told him that guy
I don't even think he likes Kobe he's
just somebody advocating for him and
just his team uses him like yeah put us
up in this and that but I don't think he
actually cares for Kobe to tell you the
truth man you know something with Trump
I mean you know him I I'll Trump the
last time he uh messaged me was at the
fights on Saturday he saw me and he was
like looking sharp my man stay uh
theater or something like that
everybody with me freaked out because of
course that show they would look who
message me man you're a legit celeb now
bro he's Tom Cruise in Florida well he's
also Tom Cruise I mean he walked around
you can't walk anywhere every what's
funny about a fighter of his stature is
every major movie star knows who you are
so if you walk into a Hollywood party
every everybody from Will Smith to
whoever it might be can you use it
though you're not giving me like is that
jorgeous there's not a lot of people
that
in the way he dresses is here like no
one's can I want to dress like that I
don't have that [__] hair I thought
this was like a la you know like very
well I don't know that's a jorgeous
the weather yeah there's a lot of [__]
that's a Miami thing a few people can
pull that off not even you can pull that
off you got to be no you should have
your own clothing line I wish bro you
step in I just don't have the hair well
hey we know you're busy brother I know
your team says you gotta roll so we
appreciate it man thank you guys some
time brother be in contact Brother
commentate and then we're gonna have him
do the squad in the ring with whoever he
picks up that guy I want that guy next
that's it bro Count Me In I'm down all
right love you guys thank you guys man